il y à il ya un fractionnement
considérable donc est ce que le parti
socialiste dans cette situation qui est
beaucoup plus délicate va tirer son
épingle du jeu et se rassure à nouveau
le parti de l'alternative moi je le
pense mais encore faut-il d'en réaliser
donc en même temps oui je pense que je
pense que 31 membres contrairement aux
sondages nous serons sur le ring dans
cinq ans pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle et tout est oui parce que
parce que ne nous était pas la barre à
l'élection municipale dans la barre
avait c'est un chemin c'est donc il faut
bien de réussir les élections
municipales si on perd les élections
municipales évidemment la présidentielle
est plus compliqué mais vous savez je
termine là dessus macron ne surprendra
plus il aura gouverné donc vous n'aurez
pas le même macron et mélenchon qui
pendant trois ans ou quatre ans aura
divisé
ça ne sera plus le même donc vous aurez
une sont une situation politique
totalement différente même si les uns
réussissent ici ou là tout sera ouvert
c'est ce que vous me dites voilà